[Music]
hmm
[Music]
i'm gonna drink the red
sorry i don't treat you like a goddess
is that what you want me to do
i'm sorry i don't treat you like you're
perfect
like all your little loyal subjects too
[Music]
hello hi everyone welcome to
stream today
i'm playing little nightmares too which
i've been very excited about for a while
um i do have to say off the jump this
stream is spon
sponsored by center cake who
i was like super on board because this
is so cool they okay so they sent me two
cakes today
and i also thought that it was very
funny to do a little nightmare stream
while
in theory advertising something that
coincides with valentine's day
um okay so they sent you this amazing
box right
so i opened one of them you can kind of
see what happened if you look at my
instagram
which one's open oh no no i'm gonna
remember which one
the other one i entirely ate the cake
this one's heavier
this has not been opened i will open it
like maybe like halfway through the
stream
um because you would think that opening
a box and revealing a cake would not be
that exciting
but the first one blew my mind so
you know
the game comes out in uh uh two days i
think
um i'm not sure if they send them to
canada but but so you guys know
basically
uh yeah send a cake sponsoring the
stream if you want to
get 10 off a cake that you can order for
anyone in your life or yourself
like i said i ate an entire cake i think
they maybe wanted me to show it off
but i ate it um there is a second one
thankfully
uh you can use the code alana 10v for 10
off and yeah you get to like
send cakes valentine's day gifts is
awesome loved ones
best friends friends whatever moms dads
who like cake
uh you can customize them they're really
neat and i would highly recommend if you
do send one to someone on give one to
someone um
that you record it you guys will see
what i mean very soon
that's all i'm saying it's nuts you're
just watching my skyliner's imaginators
review
that's pretty wild uh
yeah i'm gonna open this this the second
cake at some point through the stream
because it was honestly wildly exciting
i was like shocked um okay but for now
we are playing an equally
shocking video game again if this is a
valentine's day
stream i just figured playing a game
about nightmares is really reflective of
most of our love lives
mine's actually pretty good but most of
our love lives most of the time
just just little nightmares you know uh
will this be available later yeah i'll
leave this stream up
on uh uh youtube um i probably
didn't delete anything on on instagram
that you're referring to the booty pop
but sometimes
my instagram filter is overly aggressive
so it makes things look like they've
disappeared or been filtered or whatever
but they haven't
but it does happen uh wisniewski it is
kind of like limbo slash inside yeah
similar vipe um
gameplay is certainly different and i
think this one's supposed to be pretty
creepy
uh thank you to everyone on youtube for
recognizing the thumbnail i was pretty
proud of it
but um yeah we're gonna do it also i
keep
catching myself in the webcam because
for the first time in my entire life
i did eyeliner correctly literally the
first time ever
i'm 27. it took me this whole time
to learn how to do eyeliner and i keep
being like oh my god i can't believe how
badly i've been doing this
it's been making me look older and
and i didn't realize until i did it
correctly today which is you draw the
wings first
you don't draw the other bit you draw
the wing first and that's what i did
and i'm like oh my god
okay i'm going to click into the game
which means it could be pretty loud off
the bat just so you all know
because this is uh it's only gonna
notice it when i click into it
nope seems fine i couldn't even hear it
there you go how's the balance for you
guys let me know
and then i can change it
thank you uh the play watch listen
episode will be up on friday after it's
edited
which is just to fix the audio it's no
point watching a live production live
when you don't have to like if i could
just
put it up on friday then you don't have
to deal with the bad audio you know
can you hear anything
yeah the buzzing is my microphone i'm
sorry about that
i can't hear much let me turn it up then
how about now you can turn it the whole
way up i guess
now
some of you are saying it's good some of
you are saying you can't hear it
that's odd okay
let me i guess crank my desktop audio
then
or just change this oh no this could
blow everything out and go default
put it down
and then i guess i'm just going to need
to put it up more
my audi's been so weird at the moment
for no reason okay
how's that
yeah i think you can hear it i mean it
is where noise that is in the game to be
fair
but what you're probably hearing uh in
terms of actual fan noise is just my fan
okay cool we can hear the game um they
said to play it with a controller
so i'm gonna do that
let's go empty
i should move my mouse out of the way
the first game i really loved i really
really enjoyed it uh
yeah if you can hear the buzzing it's on
my end sorry
i don't know how to fix it so it is what
it is live production
i'm not a streamer not something i know
my way around that well
cool it seems chill
the first game also had these really
cool like
studio ghibli vibes sometimes that i was
really into
all right little buddy
where are we going
it's odd that it should be so peaceful
when it's supposed to be pretty terrible
like i'm very calm right now
okay probably wants me to jump that
that's a squid that's gonna be a squid
all right that's cool
does that make me run just asking me
jump okay
i'm not sure beautiful
love to see it um yeah they did provide
me with a code
i should i should mention that i was
given a code
uh who are you talking to bud
let me check the controls
okay we have crouch slide
move grab is either the top two okay
call sprint is x flashlight
jump throw attack look around okay so
grab was this boy
oh it was going to tell me anyway my bad
uh crouch
beautiful let's do it does this one have
nasty large meat chef last one did
i don't know about that
godzilla or kong
um
i would uh look i think they're both
cool guys
anyone who thinks godzilla is not gonna
win in that fight is ridiculous
that's all i'm gonna say
oh
what was throw i don't even
really know that i want to actually i
regret that i just did that before
recognizing what i was looking at look
at the like how messed up the toes look
oh gosh oh glide
i think we'll be just fine thank you i'm
just gonna roll out of here
come on up you go
well of course that was going to happen
i didn't mean to do that
of course
just i don't know i don't know what i
expected i'm about to jump in and i
press sprint instead
so it's a a is jump axis sprint
i still i do want to know what it what's
in there though
no i don't it's fine it's fine curiosity
in this kind of game will destroy me
we don't need it
so far very limbo-esque
okay bud let's go yeah the
first one was largely in a ship um
and i don't know
i think reviews came out this morning i
imagine for this game oh gosh
but i actually don't know where
majority of it uh takes place i don't
know if it's majority woods or anything
like that
did the first game look like this um
yeah jeff it it
it did yeah um
it is very gloomy
okay
there gonna be something i can grab for
this
hmm
i don't think i'll be able to just jump
up there oh maybe i can go inside the
aha cute that's neat
you just broke the 2d very cool
you have to grab it
cool you got it
i feel like all of this probably smells
really bad
that's all i'm gonna say none of this
smells
good at all
hmm
the animation
oh buddy i'm so sorry i did that to you
you got to see what happens uh can i do
something with this rope
nope is there something i can take over
here
mayhaps
um
i don't know about that i don't feel
like backtracking is the right option
yet
um we're gonna jump down again
and then try to hit the rope which is
also probably wrong ah
there it is i didn't have to jump the
whole way down
uh okay
it's not gonna let me climb this surely
could do oh i can okay cool
oh gosh i feel bad for laughing but just
the animation was just so abrupt i just
didn't expect
it
uh yes i will take you thank you
it's my shoe now is this another trap
all right i guess we're going to pick
this up i'm going to throw it
groovy got it gotcha
no
yeah okay i'm getting it i'm getting it
i'm getting it
we're doing it
that's another one oh that's a bear trap
oh my gosh who set all this up
why
this this the first one did this to me
too um especially with like the little
collectibles
where it has this effect where i feel
personally responsible for
the little guy um
rather than feeling like it's me i feel
like i am responsible
uh for the player character in a way
that i think is
it's not like they're a peer it's not
like it's an adventure i'm on
it's like i feel bad if something bad
happens to them and i feel like there's
not a lot of games really play with that
kind of mechanic
um but not a mechanic just an
idea um i do feel like
moss maybe well i threw it
and then i thought i was safe because i
threw it
you son of a
just you know what i was just saying
what am i just going to take this with
me
wasn't this all safe though yeah this is
what i'm going to do
seriously whoever is setting these traps
really
does not want me here um oh my god they
were all there and i just missed them
all wow
okay i didn't realize we had a pro gamer
over here
nope there you go
they were they were all there the first
time and i just missed it all
right um
yes the video game moss um psvr game i
believe
i did a similar thing where i just felt
really really like personally oh gosh
uh responsible for the little mouse i
think it was
it's accident oh boy oh
no oh heck
good thing bear trap stay shut though
all right okay okay okay
probably wasn't necessary that run and
jump there but
made me feel more comfortable so we've
done it
my gosh we've done it
this is resident evil vibes
yikes um
oh youtube chat shouldn't be set to
members only sorry about that hang on
let me um
fix that before i enter this terrifying
house via that window it's gonna lose
audio for a second
let's go um let me change it
i guess it'll just be back in somewhere
[Music]
maybe in my go live settings
i don't know if i can now
i think i got it
it says you've saved my changes
but then i don't know if you have
youtube i don't think
it has
oh but it looks like people who aren't
members are in here
i don't know what's happening over here
on the youtube
odd okay
maybe that worked i don't know
hope so okay let us continue
playing the video game let's climb
inside
creepy smelly house hey
but maybe there'll be a nine foot six
inch tall
hot vampire woman in here so you thought
about that
really changed how i feel about anything
spooky
okay this is definitely darker a lot
faster than the other game was
i also love the way they play with scale
like
any kind of video game where you grow
big usually not that fun
video games where you grow small always
a good time
um it's an achievement
thank you uh
i can't do anything in here can i i can
climb up all right look at us go
all right well i'm just gonna close this
door like the joker
uh yeah feeling small in a space i think
is always really fun
uh i feel like i give it shout outs all
the time but cronus
uh game by gunfire games is my favorite
vr game ever made
and it does a very good job of dealing
with space and i believe kronos is
actually
coming out very soon as a non-vr title i
think they just announced that sort of
recently in the last few months
um but in vr it's especially cool the
way they play with the space
there's gonna be a cat in here that'd be
cool
oh god
okay this seems fine this all seems fine
[Music]
oh thank you jeff
[Music]
i don't feel oh you guys can't see it
you can't see what i'm looking at
hang on let me take my webcam away
because you will have no idea what
yep that's a thing that's happening
[Music]
and i'm uncomfortable
all right hang on let me maybe move my
webcam up that might uh
be better for this game you can always
move it again
all right
because like honestly what could go
wrong
that's not what i wanted but that made
it look like you could shoot hoops
no i'm gonna have to like hack it or
something aren't i
okay let's try this
come on buddy ah
can't wait to go play with that [ __ ]
up kid
um okay
i thought that maybe i would oh i can
just do it this way
i would like axe please thank you
and it was i who was the pyramid head
this is super scary what am i doing to
this child now i think i may be against
my own self
and i think i'm maybe the bad guy
this poor kid dude
why are we doing him like that
he's just a kid he was just playing with
his music box this is gonna turn bad i
don't know what's gonna happen
okay
that could have gone a lot less this
i've i've had worse luck making friends
in my own life so
not so bad still think the kid who has
these chains in his bedroom
oh he's been locked in here
that's what it seems like he's been
locked in here
okay cool
drawing of the candle
you want me to grab this hook
i don't know why but
follow-up thought why not no
okay all right find out where he went
should i take my axe with me just to
continue this
terrifying pyramid head run that i'm on
excuse me
hey kid where'd you go i'm just trying
to hang out
i'm just i'm just trying to help
all right drop it get rid of it drop the
axe
okay what if i get a crawled under there
i'm not sure
yeah i'm just trying to ask you a
question
i don't know why you gotta be so afraid
oh
is that jack like from resident evil 7
are they going to make me eat food
and then run them over with a car
spoilers for roast me for 7.
so i don't love this ah for me
really at all um
[Music]
but
maybe it'll be fine
hey kid i'm just trying to ask you
something
i look like i'm floating
i think we're making friends see i chose
the perfect game for valentine's day
wait okay yeah let's go [ __ ] pick me up
it was the trigger you should have
guessed
oh boy those are sounds that are
happening
but because of the aesthetic of this
game i'm
like again you can't see it damn it i'm
frequently um
unsettled but it's not like i find it
scary like i'm like oh that's creepy but
you know like when i'm playing
the resident evil maidens demo for
example
um is he gonna boost me again
but i can hold his hand
oh excuse me
how to get uh i'm terrified that's what
i was going to say
okay
nope there somewhere else for me to go
can i climb you i cannot can we go
through this way
mayhaps there are loads of hidden areas
in the first game because that's how you
get all the collectibles can i maybe
drag this
no i'll push it
help yeah
friend
oh please don't give hints chat i didn't
thankfully i didn't see it
maybe that won't be a problem but i
would definitely prefer to figure stuff
out on my own but thank you
i appreciate it um
[Music]
but i might not i might just miss it
anyway okay
cool love that for us
i need to find a key
the way they've done their feet dude
that's a lot
oh boy
okay so we need to find some kind of
crank
can i put you in there excuse me sir
oh thank you i love having a friend
um all right
let's go let's do it
hello i assume you're just sleeping
so they are all dolls they're not real
they're all
they are all indeed fake but will they
come to life at some point
that is my question
all right let's go let's go let's go
let's go
mm-hmm i'm gonna get this key
oh thanks buddy he's so useful look at
him wow
i wonder if this game has co-op
i don't rightly know
i don't think they're wax house dolls
alyssa they're just
um buddy why'd you stop
aha okay
oh no i jumped again no doesn't matter
excellent i mean oh yes i have done the
correct thing
okay cool go back downstairs
it is noisy down there though bud i
should have left you in that room
playing your music box maybe
don't wait did i lose the key no surely
not surely it's in my inventory surely
we're fine
okay surely i may have dropped it i may
have dropped the key
i think i dropped it
okay let's go
we back outside and now it looks like
outlast everything's fine
i really like these games though um
there is fall damage i definitely died
previously
um for sure died previously
um
uh patrick i think that person is just
trolling i would i would uh time them
out if they keep doing it not that i'm
likely to see it
scariest game i've ever played i would
say silent hill pt i find it absolutely
terrifying
um but i love it though absolutely adore
it
uh scary games are my favorite um
but in other news and speaking of my
cute companion friend if you missed it
this stream is sponsored by center cake
which i thought was a very cool idea
especially as someone who is basically
in a long distance relationship with my
entire family
they sent me this little valentine's day
cake
i can't see my own webcam right now with
a little nut
and um these boxes
uh-huh uh-huh that have cakes in them
that are like fully customized
um that are really really sweet and i i
will open one
i said when would be an hour in streams
it'll be like another half hourly
um which one did i eat i keep forgetting
which one's heavier
okay so this one i've already i really
hope so otherwise it's gonna scare the
crap out of me
this is the one that i've already opened
i think so they come in this like
beautiful
little display
it's so cool um and they got these
little romantic charizards in here
and we've got um bernie sanders of
course and a whole bunch of flowers
which smell lovely
uh there was also a cake in there but i
ate it so
but you will see how much cooler it is
when i actually open it for the first
time with the other one it's almost like
they have like
a show when you work with it it's nuts
but yeah it's send a cake uh they gave
me a um a uh
uh which was a thing again i thought was
really cool this again as someone who
is distant from everyone i care about
there is a code what is it alana 10 v
you get 10 off if you would like to
order someone a cake
and i did eat that one and it was
delicious
i just thought it was a cool thing to be
on board for for valentine's day
um or just in general
um
and then i'm going to
keep playing
i just wanted to make sure i had the
code right it is alana 10 v
sandy sandycake.com the link's in the
description on youtube if you want to
check it out
very good big fan was so pleasantly
surprised by it
very very cool it's like two day
delivery or something anyway i didn't
need to talk about this for this long
let us
continue playing video game i'm gonna
open this cake in like a half hour and
i'm like it's
you'll see the jumpscare it's but it's
not really but it's super cool
so okay we have footsteps here
is somebody alive or not is my question
that you didn't put those there
where is the adult of this
situation
i could have done that but i don't even
need to it's gonna be push
come on little friend look at us go
being strong boys
okay
i can hear somebody i think
that would be correct the big general it
is a linear puzzle platformer yeah
that is how i would describe this game
oh no
okay well it's about time we saw
somebody who wanted to kill us
hey big boy
all right
this game does seem a lot more messed up
than the first one not that it wasn't
again it was also messed up
there was one part at the end with this
like i think mirror stuff if i remember
correctly or mannequins i think
she was a mannequin that i found truly
terrifying
oh okay
oh we are gonna push this
and he's he's we're just gonna act like
your boy didn't hear that
go go he's got a shotgun
oh my god well
i didn't expect that i should have just
run around it okay
oh my gosh but
you can hide i see i see i i need to
hide i got it okay
district god disregard i thought he was
just always gonna shoot the box it's
actually that that uh i'm supposed to be
hiding
and sand i'm picking up what you're
putting down
shoot it again [ __ ]
and then we'll hide behind this one and
you'll shoot it again you [ __ ]
okay cool cool cool cool
it would suck if somebody bought this
damn it i was looking at the kid and not
myself it would suck if somebody bought
this game for their kids
they're like oh little nightmares that's
you i think of you so fondly as that
exact thing
you ever play mario kart and think
you're doing great but then realize that
you're looking at somebody else's screen
for some reason
i did it again i did it again
it's all right we ran it back in
i think it's probably because oh
wow i
uh it's because he's in front and i'm
used to in a video game
the npc being behind maybe i don't know
i just keep doing it
the last one was just because i should
have dropped instead of jumped
apparently
i'll just drop down here and we won't
get shot by a shotgun
oh my god ah i thought i was gonna fall
and i
didn't i didn't run far enough oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
there you go yep good good good okay
and then just keep running do not stand
on the ledge
it's like a lot of the rings
stop breathing
don't worry about it no we're not out
here
everybody's be quiet it's a lot of the
rings
oh you want to hold my head okay
there is nowhere to hide
hide in the tall grass pokemon is that
crow gonna start some [ __ ]
are you about to start a fight with me
crow
[ __ ] knew it well okay now we're
gonna run again you son of a [ __ ] no
he's gonna kill me
all right don't let crow
[Applause]
yeah absolute prick okay where do you
want to go then
i think the crow is going to start some
[ __ ] again
but maybe he will leave no
no he won't leave no he won't
i'll figure it out okay
he just didn't see us got it okay okay
okay okay
it's fine tall grass can hide in is what
this tutorial is
teaching me i am pokey man
with my pokemon best friend we're gonna
be fine
everything's gonna be fine
but could you just [ __ ] up back home
then you
i would like to get in that hole
okay cool
nope no no we're gonna wait until he
goes back that side
i'm just gonna wait i'm gonna wait it
out
definitely not visible
crawl into a hole that
snake and or spider has almost
definitely been in it's fine that was
scripted [ __ ]
i gotta go faster there it's like it's a
bit too that's that's better to time out
surely
damn it
do not worry about crow
crow doesn't matter
and then run to final hole
got it sorted we're gonna be fine
i wonder if i could sprint to it
bye [ __ ] okay sweet we've done it
what you can't get down here no what
i did not expect him to be able to do
that it's fine it's fine
it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's totally fine
it's not a problem i specifically just
said it was fine
we're okay i'm just gonna time the
person out on youtube you guys if you
guys aren't gonna do it i'm gonna do it
there you go all right keep going uh how
is this game so far i'm definitely still
in like a tutorial area but
uh i really like the fast one i imagine
i will really like this one
um
[Music]
i i feel like giving an impressions on
the game after 40 minutes is
is a little bit tough
but uh into it so far i mean regardless
i will finish this game there's like no
question
am i gonna make that jump i feel like
i'm probably not gonna make that jump
but we can try who cares if i die you
know
it's fine because you respawn real fast
we can risk death okay
it's gonna be all right it's gonna be
right i'm gonna fish it all now no i'm
just gonna do two hours
i would say the first game jeff was
maybe like five six hours long if i
remember correctly
um okay
could i like climb down this this is
also a risk
didn't think so um
[Music]
what's this thing how about this is this
it
beautiful
what am i gonna do though
there's a plank there could you grab
that for me king could you grab the
plank
or you're just gonna leave me here
help out do your part
oh okay
no didn't jump anywhere near far enough
but that will work i expected him to put
the plank down
he didn't maybe the pancake is not
is not what i actually think it is i
don't know
at least put it out you know jeez
useless
like is he psyching me am i getting
psyched by this kid
ah can you play this game co-op i'm
gonna google it
it'd be really cool
little nightmares to co-op
because i actually played this entire
game with someone else
um
does it have co-op just answer the
question
i think the answer is no
there is co-op and little i messed you
but it is not multiplayer
club comes in a little nightmare too
between mono and six but is restricted
to the player who's working the ai
players will control mono and you have
to work with six to complete plentiful
puzzles to escape
the omission of multiplayer co-op is
okay so
so no they phrased this very strangely
like why would you call it co-op
no you just work with six as a companion
that is not no no no no no no it offends
me that you would even call that call up
sir
okay how you think i'm about to make
that you punk
okay fine we'll try it again it's going
to be run
it's going to be jumping it's going to
be grab
run jump grab
okay but you could have just pulled down
whatever this thing is but i guess you
had to hold on to it
didn't you um
all right this looks chill great
i love this for us i think i might take
a nap right here
oh is that another friend hello
paddington paddington bear
was that you buddy my dude
um you've seen better days should be a
red hat too but whatevs
um
i would like this hat can i take this
and give it to my friend
hello oh well i can put that on
excellent you love to see it
this is very limbo inside vibes right
now
man he really wants to find us are we
important
to him for some reason
do i know you
like for real though shotgun seems just
a bit aggressive
it just feels like a bit much for these
two tiny tiny children
you know like bruv get hobbies
like do you not just masturbate even one
time
i'll make everything better for you i
promise
i didn't even consider it oh [ __ ]
oh
okay
have you considered having sex
good stress reliever if that's not an
option for you for whatever reason
try reading an erotic magazine
or come here maybe
um pornhub potentially
there are actually a lot of options for
for this particular kind of stress
relief that might make you less
aggressive
in 2020 [ __ ] [ __ ] you
i would slap you kid stop me from
getting behind
stump 2
stump 2 is strong good news
everyone
what's this
it's so cute
uh i see it's a cover
before we go under this can't be good
for either of us
like is this like what are we swimming
in
i bet you this smells terrible i think
that i should just
for my fixation on this being as
consistent as as it is
i really feel like i should start some
kind of blog that is just
what does this video game smell like
where i go into
some kind of like intense detail about
how i picture
certain games smelling and that fixation
definitely started with bloodborne
i just had a yeah but what does blood
one smell like though kind of reaction
to bloodborne
and now i'm like what does this smell
like sulfur i think this smells like
sulfur
what does donut county smell like
i feel like donut county like am i about
to get a shotgun
is this game like pro gun
did the nra sponsor this am i about to
shoot this man
oh my god
look in this instance
i'm all right with it
i'm alright with it i didn't expect it
but my reaction is a positive one and
also really good sound design there
kicking the audio out as a reaction to
letting up a shotgun
that is good sound design hello friend
hold my hand please i would like to sail
with you
on this door
wait nope nope i'm pushing the wrong
thing excuse me mate
okay here we go
let's go let's go let's go let's go cool
yeah good stuff
good stuff
is that a boat in the background
i don't know i it's possible that this
is in the same
universe or even the same character as
the first game i played the first game
when it came out so
it would have been maybe 2016 2017
i think um but that means i don't
remember it
tremendously well but it is possible
that
they are connected um that world ended
up being really cool
i'm sure this one will be fun too 2017
checks out
[Laughter]
i'm laughing at that comment cody how is
door moving
a good question don't worry about it i'm
playing mono he's new six the girl is
your companion as the original character
from one
really oh yeah i guess the hair was a
thing wasn't it
so then yeah my brain
i really don't remember the story well
enough to piece them together to be like
how did she end up in that room i don't
recall
but that's cool thank you for letting me
know
yeah i'm not sure why she got captured i
don't i don't remember
um yeah don't worry about the door all
right it's magic
there are if that's the only question
you have about this game i don't know
what to tell you
is this a ship or is this a town
oh the building moved
hello buddy i see you and you also
very cool design very cool
can we hold hands well let me
very sad
come on
oh are you friend
or foe
hello
did i do good is this a good thing that
i just did
i am not sure
i miss the beach all right
level two i suppose
josh it's just it's just so creepy the
collectibles
that make sense it is bandai
yeah not made by them but
um published here or at least
distributed
i think distribution's probably more
likely but i'm not
i'm not sure it's you know it's honestly
a pleasure not having to know that kind
of [ __ ] anymore
the fact that i i'm like you know i
stopped being a game journalist as soon
as i left ign is how i felt about it and
what i kept saying
but um you know i still had to cover
news at inside gaming
the fact that i don't have to worry
about any of that kind of thing anymore
it's great
you just know what i know and i don't
have to worry about what i don't know
and it's wonderful
you'll be like i don't know don't
remember it's
really is good um okay
i don't i feel like i probably should
have explored the street a bit more
but i think i'll probably replay the
game
on xbox in any case
i wonder what the tv vibe is about are
you gonna make some meta commentary on
on tv being bad hey you wanna boost me
cute little boost thank you
hmm
indeed okay
this is neat i'm a fan
uh being forced to play a game pump out
a review kind of kill any enjoyment you
had with gaming at the time
no so i've always had people ask me um
if i ever stopped enjoying games while
while reviewing games
never uh it's never never bothered me at
all
i love smashing through games
no facet of the last 10 years that i've
spent working in the games industry has
ever
had a negative impact on how much i
appreci appreciate video games it's
actually pretty exciting my um
my 10-year anniversary in the games
industry
will be in may that will be
uh nope
the sound i knew it was bad before i
even did it um which i think is around
the same time that i'll be at like
six months at uh santa monica studio
okay we run
we jump aha
that sound
what's my favorite experience of that 10
years
i have no idea no a lot of very good
ones
i know a lot of really cool people that
that always
sometimes i have moments where i'm just
like
oh i'm friends with this person that i
like have loved my whole life and that
that trips me out sometimes
this game is very cool this art style
is is or just the artistic vision i hate
saying artistic though because it sounds
like i'm saying autistic
because the way australians pronounce it
artistic
the artistic vision is uh
just extremely cool
you want me to go towards it i think you
might
okay do i have to go turn it off or am i
gonna die
[Music]
i don't know man i'm tripping balls
it's cool as hell
hell yeah dude
i am down let's do this
neat
this is uh from the very start of the
game
yep um salt yup
yes super into it
oh my gosh how cool we officially have
a mystery that i am extremely intrigued
by
very cool what time is it how long have
i been streaming for
is it time for me to open cake oh it is
let's take a little break right here so
i can open this cake
you guys ready the stream is sponsored
bye
send a cake uh they are currently
promoting that they are doing
valentine's day cake deliveries um
[Music]
yeah they gave me a code what is it a
lot of 10v for 10 off
the link is in the description on
youtube basically like can deliver cakes
which
again as a person who is extremely
remote from everyone in my life really
most people at least um i was like hell
yeah and they're very very creative
so okay i'm gonna open the second one
it could i don't know what it's gonna
look like it could be wild which one is
it again
it gets this one the first one i did not
expect it to be like this when i opened
it
i know that sounds absurd you're like
alana it's a cake but it's so much more
than that
are you ready okay
[Laughter]
it's so cool
oh my gosh i have a butterfly in my hair
right when i was saying like i want to
do this
on uh a stream it was definitely my hair
has become one with this particular
butterfly
um i was definitely not just like no
that's dumb
it's like so much cooler than you would
think it is but i have now become
attached to this butterfly so we gotta
fix that
excuse me i would like to have my hair
back if i could have my own hair back
that would be super cool
this is what happens when you have too
much hair give it back
hey oh that's quite no that's quite
twisted
you've definitely consumed my hair
alrighty here we go
beautiful um and then
it's just so cool uh-huh uh-huh
here you go beautiful cake with a bunch
of flowers on the inside
and you can kind of customize whatever
it is that you want to send
i just think it's so cool
and i don't i don't know like how many
different varieties of that they have
but this one i suppose butterflies fly
out of
um in real time and it actually sounds
like them
so neat so yeah uh i i was totally down
to do a sponsorship with them for
for valentine's day to promote
valentine's day but you know in general
as a cool thing to send someone that is
like
a a treat but also just like such a
creative way to do that
um you know i have all these flowers
everywhere
i think it's awesome uh
what do i need to tell you about them
they're easy to order two day delivery
available you can customize the the
pictures that are inside as well
which is super neat um yeah they
recommend recording people's reactions
to opening them because they are often
really surprised because again you look
at this box and you're like i'm just
gonna get
a cake there probably is a glitter
explosion one i don't know
um and i i just requested chocolate
cakes that's all i asked for i had no
idea
um what exactly the reveal was going to
be when i opened them so
super cool yeah it says that each of
them is not only a present but an
experience with cake and surprises all
in one and i totally agree with that so
yeah if you want to check it out you can
go to alana
no no no it's centercake.com and the
code i have for you guys for 10 off if
you want to get one is alanna 10v
and the cake is also delicious i ate one
of them so
i too am planning to get wine drunk
death egg on valentine's day
we'll see how it goes
so good um yep well this cake is
is one i just opened it's definitely
like fully wrapped up so they deliver it
like in a way that um again this is not
required for the sponsorship i'm just
talking to you guys because i genuinely
think these cakes are cool
uh it's like they do fully wrap them so
it's wrapped on the outside and on the
inside so they can deliver them safely
but uh yeah did already eat one it was
delicious and like very
nicely coated in it's like um
i don't know if this is correct but it
seemed to me like it was sugar that had
been burned because it was like a crispy
kind of sugary flavor that i was a big
fan of um so yeah there's that
just very cool i'm definitely not going
to stream on valentine's day
uh i generally don't like care a ton
about that kind of holiday
where it's required to buy thing people
things again but i also am a big fan of
um
of of giving people gifts uh and romance
yeah let me give you guys a gift a link
sorry hang on here we go
the link is here
they probably have like yeah obviously
right now they're talking about
valentine's day but
um so i got a explosion box with
butterflies
is what that was explosion box with
butterfly surprise
they have a ton of explosion boxes again
this is i am now at this point just
talking about this because i want to
yeah it looks like you can get a bunch
of different kinds of uh
explosion boxes they have teddies in
some of them
i just think it's really cool
okay let me make myself small again and
continue playing the video game for the
people
who don't care about my interest in
these cool cakes but if you do want one
i'll on a 10v 10 off let me write that
down just so that you guys have that too
but all on the youtube video all that
details on there i should have put it on
twitch
and i am uh still planning to
yeah labeled on the site as explosion
boxes jared um planning to
go just to twitch at some point or
partner on twitch at some point i just
haven't really made my mind up about
when or how
but um we are at a point where i
consistently have more viewers on twitch
than youtube and that took
a pretty long time so
let's keep playing video game what am i
doing on valentine's day
just chilling um i do have a thing that
we just announced today
that uh
is bright spot live 2 the second one is
happening
on this saturday i will be djing that
again
i won't give out any more details about
it other than that it is a live talk
show but extremely socially distance we
have
even less people actually together in
theory aside from the person who gives
me my test
uh i won't even really be close to
anyone
um yeah the one i did with ethan it's
basically the idea is that uh
it's about giving people a good time
during cloven and raising money for
charity of course
uh probably wouldn't do it if that
weren't the case so it should be fun
i have not figured out what kind of
music i'm going to play yet i'll
probably find another way to do
more deep house but uh try and make it
royalty free
but yeah we just um announced that today
so
it should be cool that is not the right
way to go
is this the right way to go i have
hiccups
that's a blank wall
how about this am i supposed to climb up
you buddy
is this the plan
yet no
are you sure because it's lit and
usually things are lit if you are
supposed to go up there
uh tony costa i do stream on both
platforms the chats are not difficult to
manage
um how about this
is this it uh i just have them
aggregated into one chat
so it's just they're both together i can
see which platform someone's commented
from but it's all in the same screen
it's not
jumping between two or anything
um
maybe we push push this baby
the light is definitely here that is
where they want me oh there's a hole
behind it push it it's gonna be pushing
from
where am i i have lost myself behind a
trash can
oh there's wheels on it yeah this is
totally gonna be it okay we're gonna go
here and we're going to push
no pull maybe from over here
there we go see that
is smart design i the player
even in a space that is quite large and
looks relatively organic
was aware that i needed to go behind
here
even though i didn't see it initially
just because that's where the light was
oh no a school the spookiest of
buildings
i have always been terrified of a school
okay go on the other side it's about to
get lit
get get on here you dummy please
come on mate yeah
[Music]
but the other have you never been on
what are you even friends with me for if
we can't do see-saw properly you
dummy uh-huh
can you push me bro hey but could you
push me though
can you push me on this on the swing
this is the worst valentine's day i've
ever had
what if i grab it what if i
do you understand now
ridiculous you get locked up
your whole life in in some creepy house
with the guy with the shotgun and
suddenly
you don't know how to play with other
kids
hey bud [ __ ]
cool tricky what are you doing
is this you telling me that i should try
and help you
because i don't feel like it is
no we go in-house
slash school
okay cool
let's go are you gonna help
or is this not the way in it might not
be
why did that make that sound
i don't like it but i guess i'm doing it
uh-huh
here we go
there we go got it don't worry about me
i have perspective issues
it's fine it's not a problem
not sure why we're here though wait okay
um
it's the cutest basketball i've ever
seen
okay well that's gonna make a bell ring
i don't know that i want to do this but
we didn't didn't like any of that
no no i'm sure that had a purpose but i
think that i will be leaving thank you
is this a hat no just a ball
what's this
why
what do you have box for
okay
what but why did you grab box
okay i have to figure out what it is
that i'm trying to do before i can
figure out how to solve the
mysteries i think maybe we need to go
turn the light back off
it's so [ __ ] up dude
honestly that's a yikes if ever i've
seen one but i guess the
the idea is that it's telling me that i
need to get over that way
oh it doesn't do anything you okay
box
still not sure why but i have it so
that's neat
didn't mean to pick that up um we've got
x
wait a is jump not x
a
let's get out of here
yeah um maybe jump to bed
but you never done a pull-up kid come on
and two and three
actually this kid is like pretty tough
like i don't know
you're still going i don't think i have
the strength to do that
it is good form like you're going the
whole way up you even seem to be lifting
like i can barely do one pull-up
okay
all right is this a corn on the cob
i can't get up there either
nope still going not even breaking a
sweat
like honestly the rope pull thing is
actually also really hard
um there's gotta be something for me to
do in here like the the way they climbed
up the
um surely i can pull this you seem like
a pulley thing
uh through the window that would be
super difficult
get out get get
try it maybe i can't it's just the fact
that there's a shine on that thing makes
me want it
that doesn't mean i need to get on it
um okay i still would like to know why
you grabbed box
and could you tell me what it means
is the main character tiny is everything
else giant i think the main character is
tiny
i think
did do you have covered but you get the
[ __ ] away from me
i don't know i don't know um
it still feels like this is what i'm
supposed to do
but to what extent um
i can't like make my way around to climb
up
okay can i maybe throw something at the
socks
like over here no
seriously is that a corn on the cob or a
dildo i can't tell which one it is
um
i just feel like i want the hacksaw up
there but
i don't know maybe maybe i'm
being led astray well that
is that sound new
i'm just going to throw this at this
creepy painting
just sort of see what happens
checks out okay cool what it was trying
to do there
was tell me there was a room behind here
which is what i gathered
but i also thought there would be
something maybe more complicated
with the other room because it was
sizeable
well this is going to open in it you
know
no do i maybe need to bring something in
here now or
it's probably because i can still get
back out oh no i can't
okay well that's helpful actually um
spoon
no um chair
hmm
oh
oh i see okay cool
you probably want me to jump off the
chair under here but
it's cool we doing it we doing it anyway
maybe yeah neat
oh it's dark oh it is quite dark
i am spooked
so
okay
why are we here you know
and other great mysteries of life
maybe we're just passing through the
school with our end goal of just being
to get really far away
i'm not sure
oh god oh heck
it's possible i don't need to interact
with this
but it is making me want to i want to
know what's up with that duck
yeah that tracks okay
i would like this no don't do it don't
do it you don't need it
i just wanna i just want the ball and i
wanna like maybe throw it at the duck
which i understand is not necessary
and probably a risk but
maybe i can't pick it up pick it up pick
it up
get it throw it at duck oh we trying to
shoot hoops out here are we missing by
miles pick it get it get it get it get
it
i don't think it can be done
okay
what's that hmm oh
i feel like the kids in this world are
unanimously friendly
but i don't know if that's i just have
the wrong read on that
why is this here
you want me to hide from somebody don't
you
hmm
who is setting up these traps
what did i do to you
hey kid what
like are you gonna attack me if i come
this way
you thought you had me but i was too
focused on this teddy bear
which i now can't see which is a shame
so i see that there's a gap there but i
want to try and go back to this door
first again because of the light
so many shoes
that should not have scared me that much
i just didn't expect it okay oh
it's correct it's this way
okay let's go come on i think
am i wrong let me go up here
just climb over
hello
i was waiting for the floor to fall in
and i was like i'll just let it happen
and see
but it's still just one of those roof
traps
that they are using kids to to
to uh kids toys to lure them out that's
that's [ __ ] up
actually that means they are trying to
attack children
i think
can't see anything on the ceiling in
here
this looks like a steppy one though
no
this is some real home alone vibes
like these kids are killing it
that was super rude
oh no they're missing their heads
ah you took my friend
what the [ __ ]
i will [ __ ] you up dude oh i was too
slow
i this time hang on give me a second
i will
i will [ __ ] you up dude i don't feel
great about it
though but i will do it
and then show remorse afterwards do i
need to [ __ ] you up too because i
[ __ ] will
all you kids is dead
you creepy porcelain
trap setting some of my [ __ ]
it's the same every time you step on a
trap something swings from the ceiling
but the animations are so funny
that i feel like i should just let it
happen i didn't that time that wasn't
i'm not i'm not sick i'm just not
noticing it but
oh my god that was funny
uh and then we do the same teammate or
we could just trigger the thing
and then run away right oh
no
punk
maybe your traps is my traps after all
but homest owns the trap in the end
ew what are you doing is he eating a
dead frog
that's i think that's a toy
but who knows
hit me basketball head cometh for your
ass
unkillable
trying to find my friend six
who put this horse in here is a horse
drawing
somebody
no somebody drew a pony and i would like
to open this
to reveal pony that's a dog [ __ ]
yes
[Laughter]
yep so
not a pony but there is a collectible
here somewhere
right because i'm i've gone all colorful
there you go kid no don't swing back
damn you physics thank you
oh god okay i need a key
roger that who's making noise
you're a stupid punk oh
hello i see that you are sizable
and that does me a concern
don't be vibrated why is it vibrating
it's definitely vibrating out here but
i'm not sure why um okay
why the vibrates is it telling me
there's a threat
what if i just pretend to be in school
then
i feel like it would be fine
uh
it's about to get more [ __ ] up isn't
it
just keep doing your writing please [ __ ]
oh
okay
guess i should i'm gonna open this
preemptively
yeah no no i guess not okay
well we're gonna pull this and then jump
off it
then we're gonna grab this key and then
we're gonna [ __ ] peace out
ah oh god
it just seems like it would have been
easier to walk
i was not expecting that
and now that i don't understand the
parameters a little creepy
ooh very creepy
of this woman's body i find her
a little bit scarier than i did before
like i don't know where you can go what
you can look at
it could be limitless
i'm taking a risk i'm taking a risk i'm
taking a risk i'm taking a risk
these kids are all already so upset
because they all have bowl cuts
i'm just not sure why you have to make
it worse for them line of sight line of
sight line of sight line of sight [ __ ]
run run no why did you stop running oh
she ate me oh yikes okay
okay
duck
i still feel like behind the desk was
probably the right way to go
just not i'm not positive
i should at least just see what she does
huh
i hate you i'm i'm not a fan of
anything that you well
why we get stuck there just got stuck on
the corner okay
she's looking in the other direction
oh she saw me nope
hmm okay i really could have thought
that i was fine i suppose
not okay
i think maybe i need to
do better stealth rather than just
running out in the open
well okay oh well i just forgot to hit
the left trigger
that one doesn't seem like it was fair
okay yeah i just forgot to crouch and
then you came at me
how could you even ever know that i was
i was the one who opened the door he did
i didn't have any part of that
just [ __ ] off spooky [ __ ]
okay strategy two
this seems like it's probably got more
cover if i do it this way
she hits this kid's desk i think
i don't know why though
a kid what did they do to you you trying
to bully the ones who
don't have bowl cuts into having bowl
cuts so they feel the same self-loathing
that you do
turn around
i can't see what you are you you psycho
i could see which way she was facing you
know
seems like she's far away
she was facing away that's when i should
have gone
damn it okay
i think like how janky her movement
style is in virtually any other game
would not work but like
something about her just being this like
clumbering
messy
it's great
what has this kid done oh that kid's
missing part of his head
oh my oh wow
[ __ ] how you keep seeing me here get
the [ __ ] out
ah
your neck not gonna reach this far you
psycho
oh no [ __ ] it's crazy
yikes um yeah i'm a big fan of this game
this is my hot take i'm really into this
oh hello numb
oh oh
oh i thought that he'd be friendly
which is a mistake i keep making is that
i thought because
it was a kid who's like locked up that
he'd be a good guy
i was round
psych
no you're also made of whatever the [ __ ]
it is
you're made of creepy little punk
i probably need to get that tool don't i
damn it okay we gotta loop you back this
way then i think
good thing you're an idiot
not me
that sorry about your face
okay
beautiful oh my gosh we've done it
is it like a dunce cap like in gta
online
like they're just making them all wear
dunce caps because they've been bad on
the server
did you blow up too many other kids did
you spawn a tank in
is that what you did
she beaten a meat sounds like
she spanking herself
okay yeah keep doing that
because i am bad at platforming
and always have been
i think that didn't happen last time oh
boy
oh no oh i don't like that at all
no
thinks you could leave go back to
spanking
are we gonna do this on repeat then is
that
the plan
get leave
please
okay i think maybe i have to jump but
i'm not confident
jumped okay
okay okay okay okay okay
come on bud and then you're gonna have
to jump up here
thank god we made it i can't really made
it
i again i don't know the parameters of
her neck
and thus i'm not entirely sure
quite how far she can stretch it
um which makes her pretty formidable foe
if you ask me oh well
okay that's cool i'm gonna go back this
way
push this
then she's gonna come and try and [ __ ]
me up faster so i'm gonna hide
behind you
no no we don't like it we don't i'm not
i'm
go away come back
have you heard how creaky this entire
building is and you're gonna try and
come at me
oh cigarettes here one of these kids is
smoking it seems like you should
deal with the smoking problem amongst
your students more so than
whatever your beef with me is
she's just terrifying snake woman
okay okay bye i hope i never see you
again in my [ __ ] life
i'm gonna see her again
she didn't like that she didn't like it
she's moving
she's moving we don't like it when they
move oh no
this is actually my worst nightmare
okay i don't know where she is is the
problem
probably should have moved that i
suspect
there's a hat there oh i would like hat
she's gonna hear this though where am i
gonna hide
maybe she just won't hear it
okay
i take hat now
look at me go getting hats
what what
are you oh i should have got one of
those and i missed it
oh there are way more hats than i
thought oh the little one with the
damn okay
move this over did i get raided oh thank
you
oh damian what's up hi damian's friends
how are you all doing damien is a good
dude
real swell guy um
thanks for joining me uh if you're all
smosh people
like i should mention my second um
maybe now it's not a good time to
mention that my second uh mangas video
is gonna be up on my channel uh
on thursday
oh god oh god oh god oh god i got okay
um i just felt like i should share my
perspective of defending courtney miller
against ian hecox who just brutally
accused her of something that she didn't
do
no
i don't like any of it
all right go up on this one i think
yeah whoo okay
i'm just gonna jump over here and it's
gonna knock a thing oh what the
it's my own fault she didn't even do
that
um the second game is not out yet bar
boat it is
uh i am playing a review build so maybe
things are subject to change i'm not
sure
um but the game is
out next week i think
jump kid don't look down don't look down
don't look down don't look down
please don't look please don't look
please don't look
okay oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh well i didn't think that you would do
that
damn it god damn
um to the people asking about um
the next episode of play watch listen
that was filmed today yeah i'll be
uploading it on friday as normal
um if it didn't have the audio issues i
would just leave it up there was one
i feel like we did okay but because
there were so many complaints on the
live chat
i uh
why is there a heidi box right there
am i not supposed to go in here that's
odd
um i'll just put up the edited version
when we have it done
okay
it seems like i'm supposed to be here
but that i can't see anything to do here
hmm
i mean i don't want to go nearer anyway
um it's so dark i can't see
do you want me to jump back the other
way
hmm
pull up king at it again no okay
it does look like there's a little shelf
up there but i don't know if i'm
supposed to be doing this like i could
i'm not sure what happened to the dj
streams i stopped doing them because i
was doing them
for uh well i am doing a dj stream this
saturday
um i was doing them for to just bring
people good vibes
um the mixes are not very good and i
know that
but then people just started coming in
and hating on them because as women
uh you just can't do anything it becomes
a [ __ ] off stupid girl dj sucks you're
ruining the scene
so which doesn't really bother me to be
clear i was like fine but um when it
just it just
felt like it defeated the purpose um
if i was trying to do something for
positive reasons if people were just
shitty about it that i was like well
oh this has been dragged aha
where am i taking it
i see that somebody has dragged you but
where do i need you to go
i'm not sure
not here what am i trying to climb it's
got to be moving up
just this side nope
okay
i don't know about this
i just feel like that top thing looks
like a thing that i should be able to
climb through but
i don't think this is right um okay
we have identified that i can drab grab
this box but then
what to do what to do
um
have there been mechanics you enjoyed in
a review build of a game that didn't
show up in the final product
i don't know about a review build but
that stuff happens in preview builds all
the time
um which i will have a video
about pretty soon okay what do you want
me to climb
what am i missing i know that i can
climb
that um
like i don't i'm not sure where to go in
here
there's a grate up there there's
hmm
maybe the door
i don't feel like i want to follow her
is my only beef with the door
but i can get it there let's see
it's odd that i can't go to the left
that seems really strange but whatever
um okay
and then that okay cool
but i really would prefer to never see
this [ __ ] lady ever again in my life
if you know what i mean
hmm
i feel like we're getting through the
school that's a thing that's exciting
for us
we need another key understood
who lit these books on fire
i just wanted to see if this is a thing
i could actually jump on
maybe not no okay okay fine
i will not oh i should uh do sponsorship
thing
i don't know the books are evil i don't
know about that
um yeah hi everyone this stream is
sponsored by cinder cake
who i was like stoked to work with
because i thought they were really cool
at like an hour into this stream we
opened up a cake and and
and it's much cooler than you would
imagine i guess i can show you for
anyone who's just joining us
what it looks like but you won't see the
full effect but this is
my cake
and it comes to you as uh this is called
an explosive box
that basically
spawned uh butterflies
through my apartment it's extremely cool
um
i have a link that i will drop all of
you here you go
well that's the discount code actually
so the discount code
is alana 10v for 10 off and then if i
give you the link
that is here well they're small cakes
which i think is nice because
it's i have tasted the cake yes i ate
the entirety of the lost cake
steampunk um assassin which they maybe
probably didn't want me to do
but i as soon as i saw it i ate the
whole thing and it's small and i like
that about it
not a giant cake um so yeah
it's a company called send a cake um
the website at centercake.com and
basically they let you send cakes that
are
cool surprises and kind of more like an
event than just sending someone a cake
which is what i think is neat about it
again as someone who
is very far from everyone i know
um you can fully customize them this has
charizards and bernie sanders
inside of it which is lovely and
yeah they're delicious and unique and
very cool
and i'm gonna have to clean up all these
flowers but it's for sure a cool thing
so thank you to them sponsoring the
street
um bandai gave me the code but it's not
sponsored by bandai but thank you to
banda for giving me the code for this
video
game and let's continue playing shall we
i think i'll probably wrap up pretty
soon
because it's yeah it's 9 10. i'll
probably finish in maybe i'll do like
another 10 minutes or so
is what i figure
so many flowers okay
let's go
i would like to get my friend back
nothing here just a collectible
thank you i will absorb your entire
being
don't worry about it it's fine
okay you gonna talk me with the dog
[ __ ] again
really
i feel like i got troubled by a video
game
and um i'm upset that's all i'm gonna
say
i'm upset ooh giant chess
well surely i can grab this
you put this here this isn't gonna work
there's no way surely not
nah okay
oh look at those creepy kids [ __ ] them
kids
what was this nothing
i'm thinking the clock
nope
it's real dark up here
should i kick these bottles and see what
happens maybe
this is a noose that kid was on a noose
anything i don't know why but
nice like idiot
kind of wondered if maybe something
would happen
that one didn't even break that one
didn't even break
um okay
i think that that i expected to be able
to climb across the clock for some
reason but i'm just thinking of framed
oh
buddy so it probably is something to
actually do with the chess pieces
if i'm thinking correctly
because why else would they be here
um can i connect these two
like you oh oh that's going to be how
you open the door
cool no no no no
put it back on or do i maybe move it
first
uh can i push you no
and now jump to it cool
i liked that
why don't trust me he's got a face on it
yeah no hints the good news is that i'm
missing them
but uh please don't give hints
i think that maybe i'm far enough ahead
though i have like a minute delay on
this
stream i'm pretty sure uh it's not that
much but that means that i keep missing
them
so that's good
but yeah i definitely prefer to figure
it out by myself i've given the
opportunity but thank you for being
helpful i definitely appreciate that
that's what you're trying to do
okay
that's [ __ ] up
these have wheels
hmm i don't feel like i'm going to be
able to do anything about that yet
though i probably got to get to this guy
somehow can we knock him down
oh
no not like that um
okay
bruv
it's just piece placement i mean the
pieces don't okay yeah i'm going to have
to find all the pieces i understand i
understand
oh thank you streamer now
totally that's what's up
cool um this
is going to be the top
left piece
right here
all right um
i'm gonna go grab the this piece back
i don't know where it went though
that is here
you know uh i started trying to watch
queen's gambit um
i just was not into it um which i feel
like
doesn't happen all that often with shows
that
my friends love or critics love or
whatever i watched like three episodes
and was like hmm
the content of this is not gripping me
um
i don't know that's is that me that kind
of does look like actual
me uh how do i get high enough for you
that's my question
i know i can't throw this high enough
i'd love to
but i can't i can't climb you
i wonder if it is something to use this
way how am i liking the game
uh well it's been almost two hours now
almost exactly and i'm really liking it
super into it i will definitely finish
it
keep wondering if maybe i can jump onto
these no
um hmm
so sorry buddy it really does suck to be
you
you know what if we maybe draw that one
back over there and then jump on it can
i do that
that is gonna be it it's then i'm gonna
have to swap this hat out i think
and then jump back up there yeah
probably that was dramatic
i'll just drop you here grab you
shot jump
and jump cool excuse me
thank you i think that this went
there i think maybe grab this one again
i might have to check that i'm not
positive
i think that one might be wrong
got to move
your ass to here
and now can i pull these open
i want the sword it looks cool
nope
no from the front
there's got to be something obvious that
i'm missing here
how to open
i mean i heard it unlock
excuse me open please
yes hello
oh is the crown not one of the hats
that's a good point i don't know
i don't think i can just take a dude's
hat though nah
you boys really had a rough time
it's a real shame
um devastated does it not say what game
it is on twitch it should right
i think i wrote it correctly that it
should say i would like to be able to
pull you
did i missed something maybe somewhere
maybe
not that that's all correct
my body's so creepy oh is that a thing
that looks like a
what is this oh damn it i thought that
was gonna be like a um what are they
called
slingshot but but no
um hmm
maybe i need to take this off again
no that wouldn't be right go back on
i'm sorry that i took you off ever nope
maybe i'll go over this way
that poor kid dude for real
okay
um
remember that this game is very good
about directional lighting
okay something bad is going to happen
this [ __ ] dog
i was really excited about the pony
drawing
here we are
i'm gonna get chased or some [ __ ] i feel
it i feel it i feel it
it is not going to go down well for me
this is not going to be good time
there is no no way
you know what to do okay let's get out
of here
okay maybe this time it was chill
god this game's so gross
okay
dildo or sausage can you tell me
i wonder if i can open that door it
looks like one of those swinging doors
something is definitely screaming
has mike played this yet uh
um not that i'm aware of i don't think
anyone on
the rest of the play watchlist and team
play video games quite as much as i do
um that's why it's not a podcast about
game releases you know um
yeah i don't think they play all of them
or anything like that certainly not
their jobs too i'm
tremendously talented at what they do no
matter how they do it
this is just like the first game scary
kitchen [ __ ]
um all right i actually think i'm gonna
leave it there you guys
before we figure out what the source of
that noise is so i can wrap my night up
but thank you for joining me
[Music]
uh what is happening in this building is
a good question go unrepentant
it is a school
something bad is happening but i'm not
entirely sure what
thank you jared i will enjoy the cake
thank you too
sunday cake for sponsoring the stream
with a beautiful cake that just hit me
in the face
so good though yeah there's a link in
the description
on youtube if you want to check them out
i will drop it in the chat again real
quick because i have a discount code for
you all
in case anyone wants to send anyone a
cool valentine's day cake you can do
that
here we go if you would like it
obviously
uh code is alana 10v for 10 off
papa if anyone wants to use it yeah
they're like customizable you can upload
pictures
ordering is supposed to be super easy um
super unique
definitely a really fun thing i think
it's cool
and um that is it for me today everyone
i will see you